back everybody police are trying to
figure out why a man in his 70s opened
fire inside of a ballroom dance club
during Lunar New Year celebrations and
we have just learned that that death
toll has now risen to 11. police say 72
year old who con Tran shot himself
inside of a van on Sunday when officers
moved in to capture him less than 24
hours earlier authorities say Tran
killed at least 11 people inside star
ballroom dance studio in Monterey Park
California 10 others were wounded police
think Tran might have targeted specific
people that he knew but they're still
trying to put all the pieces together of
this case all the victims were in their
50s 60s and 70s law enforcement revealed
Monday that tran visited a police
station in Hemet California recently
where he was living in a mobile home
park he wanted to report that he
believed his family was poisoning him
the tragedy though could have been much
worse because Tran left the Monterey
Park dance studio and drove to nearby
Alhambra California to another Ballroom
location but when he got inside the
lobby about 30 minutes before closing
time a man working there spotted him ABC
News spoke with that young man who got
the gun away from the suspect before he
could hurt anyone at that second
location
I needed to take this weapon disarm him
or else everybody would have died when I
got the courage I lunged at him with
both my hands
grabbed the weapon
and we had to struggle finally at one
point I was able to pull the gun away
from him shove him aside create some
distance
point the gun at him intimidate him shot
him and say
get the hell out here I'll shoot get
away go
Brian the shooter's dead there's not
going to be a trial was there any reason
to continue investigating what happened
here yes Jesse because it's not about
what just happened here it's about
trying to prevent what could happen in
the future you want to try to create
some sort of a psychological or a
profile generally for this individual to
see like you said is it him targeting
people he knew was he targeting the the
Lunar New Year because he knew that
people were going to be in that area
this is a predominantly East Asian
community and he's a part of that
Community he said that many of his
victims would have even known him and so
they're trying to see if this is any one
of the many reasons that people
um commit these mass shootings but the
harsh reality is this keeps happening in
this country we're trying to figure out
a way to stop this I think this is the
worst shooting since Uvaldi and we keep
saying that that this is the worst
shooting since so this is a way of
trying to figure out how to stop having
to say that over and over again okay so
like Brian said Terry about the future
if this crime was motivated by hate what
can more would be done to prevent these
types of shootings these types of
incidents you're not I think we need to
do proactive work here we need to look
at social media see who's writing are
there groups behind this can we stop it
before it happens is he connected to
anyone else these are questions I think
we need to ask before we have another
mass shooting like this I think also
when we do have the suspect and he
doesn't kill himself or he's not killed
by a police officer then I think if it's
motivated by hate we often really need
to make sure that the punishment is as
severe as it can be so that we can deter
and then obviously I mean it's different
in other countries you don't have these
mass shootings we do need to have more
control of these guns making sure that
they're not on the street that they're
not easily
purchased by people who should not have
them so background checks you know wait
times all of that needs to be done
all right well the city of Memphis
Tennessee was on edge Monday as the
community awaits the release of video
showing a black man's violent arrest
Tyree Nichols a 29 year old father and
FedEx worker died January 10th at the
hospital three days after a brutal
confrontation with five officers
relatives say those officers beat
Nichols and caused him to have a heart
attack authorities have only said that
he had a medical emergency lawyers for
the family say relatives did have a
chance to view the video themselves on
Monday but when that video might be made
public is unclear
all five officers were fired for using
excessive force the U.S department of
justice has opened a civil rights
investigation and the Tennessee Bureau
of Investigation is also working to
determine if further action needs to be
taken police say Nichols was pulled over
for reckless driving and there was some
kind of Confrontation in Iran when the
officers caught up to him there was
another confrontation and Nichols
complained of shortness of breath an
official cause of death hasn't been
released over the weekend a small
memorial was held for Mr Nichols
if I say anything political is this
that everywhere there is justice
there's always the possibility of
Injustice that's right
huh it has such an awesome run because
Justice is supposed to mean
righteousness
but even in the best of us
there's some worst of us